for some perspective on the busy week in
politics we turn to Bob Cusack
editor-in-chief of the hill Bob good
morning good morning the president is
right to be crowing about the GDP number
which is the best since 2014
to what degree though is that clouded by
this whole sort of beginning of a trade
war and the tariff issues that that he's
also set in motion the trade war
Republicans on capitol are very nervous
they're they're ecstatic about these new
numbers a lot of economists said you can
never get to 4% he's got to 4% at least
for the court or whether you can do it
for the whole year remains to be seen
but this is something they're nervous
it's going the impact of this of these
trade wars could be felt in the fall and
of course that's right before the
midterms we've got a hundred days to go
effective today to the election so it's
making them very nervous the White House
announced that 12 billion dollar aid
package to farmers as a result to kind
of ease the concerns over the issues
with the tariffs what what's how is that
sort of like being felt out on Capitol
Hill well it's never good when you were
referring to something as a bailout but
this is a different type of bailout
because it's a bailout from the trade
war that the Trump has started so it's a
different type of thing now farmers like
it at least because they've been so
nervous but where is it going is there
going to be some type of truce with
China is there going to be some type of
negotiation a lot of experts say listen
the US versus China China can win the
long game so this is something that a
lot of Republicans say maybe you should
have wait until after the election to do
because the House and Senate could flip
yeah especially they're looking at some
of those states especially that
obviously had so many the Trump
supporters Michael Cohen obviously we we
heard a little bit about this in the
piece about this idea that he is now
saying Trump knew in advance about this
meeting at Trump Tower with the Russians
Trump has certainly denied this in the
past and now we're hearing these
allegations that don't listen to Michael
Cohen that he's not telling the truth it
it feels like such a reversal we heard
it two months ago
Giuliani it's saying the exact opposite
but does this matter now to people to
the American people this sort of
reversal of course I think so but the
the the big question is is Robert Mahler
does it matter to robert muller and
remember Michael cone still has tapes so
when Trump says or Giuliani says X or Y
or he's not telling the truth well
does Michael Cohen have a tape that
actually proves his case so the fact
that Michael cone and Trump are now
bitter enemies is remarkable and that is
something that I think is a bad sign for
the White House you they just don't know
what's coming next what do you what do
you think Robert Muller is making of
these leaks though Bob I mean muscial
Council has all that as you mentioned
has the tapes they've big took thousands
of documents but a lot of this stuff is
leaking out he can't be happy about that
Kenny no and and I really don't think
it's coming from Muller himself but he's
gonna gather all the information and
look at what Michael Cohen wants to say
I'm sure he's interested in any type of
Cohen testimony but remember I don't
think he can actually do anything
between now and the election that's what
James Comey did he was kind his hand was
a bit forced but that's what he was
criticized for so I think in all
likelihood the Muller investigation goes
beyond the election is there is there a
fatigue factor though with the idea of
the Russia investigation as people
continue to hear about it yeah I mean
I've talked to some independent voters
and they say they're not tired of the
Russia thing however it they're bad
headlines for Trump he wants to talk
about the economy he wants to talk about
a Supreme Court nominee but there is
some Russia fatigue and that's the
question for Democrats how much they
talk about Russia post Labor Day on the
campaign trail the big question I'm sure
is what will stick and I think that's a
big question for a lot of people on both
sides of the aisle Bob Cusack thank you
thank you